we all know that crypto is the talk of
the town these days
so we came down to the miami crypto
experience to see what
everyone is talking about regarding
crypto
so you at home can get more informed and
make
some money you want to make a billion
dollars
i guarantee you a billion guarantee
let's talk money
all we talk is money
all we talk is money i'm natalie
okay natalie i'm eliza bruno sessions
bruno sessions not bruno mars don't get
confused hi guys i'm the bitcoin queen
how long have you been involved in the
crypto space 10 years in and out it's
like a bad girl
like a bad girlfriend you were in and
out and back and forth uh actually i'm
pretty new to it i got in the early run
of 2017
since 2011. i've been in a large scale
ethereum miner for about five years been
watching it for about three years
and i just jumped in last year what was
it about bitcoin or crypto that
compelled you to get involved
so the monetary system kind of um
affected me just as
growing up as a kid the 2008 recession
really hit my family hard
and i understood the value of money at a
young age um so because of that i found
the value in bitcoin and i found the
value in
alternative currencies that aren't
connected to governments honestly
i'm like a girl so i don't know that
much about it but i know that
it's big these days like doggy coin is
that one of those yeah dogecoin who's
your friend by the way uh
her name is magic magic happens magic
happens i love that
an experience like this that miami
crypto experience what happens is we
educate people
we teach from nfts to trading to mining
to tax to laws
everything is here well right now i'm on
voyager and they do a lot there that i
like with that platform as far as the
interest you get back
their savings account there that they
give you money on you know i like to go
in small i got in ripple when it was
like less than a penny
this is on the cutting edge of payment
and currency so we want to be here and
be a part of it well it's good to have
bitcoin especially in times like this
where obviously the monetary system
collapses we have a crisis but it's not
the corona virus so it's good to have
bitcoin now
and in the future it will be good to
have bitcoin rather than that versus
paper money with presidents printed on
them i saw
on instagram for the dogecoin or
whatever like there was a huge skyrocket
so there's definitely like a big benefit
involved
instead of just that asset sitting there
you're actually earning yield
every week you're turning bitcoin into
something that's just gonna appreciate
against the dollar into a
cash bearing or an interest bearing
asset and that changes the whole game
i think it's really just starting you
know they say bitcoin is going to be go
up to 100 000
so if you come in today at 50 grand you
still make 50 grand in 50 grand boom
that's double up
bought bitcoin bought a bunch of
coins so what's the difference between
bitcoin and coin bitcoin is
has a ton of advantages as far as mining
power adoption
um and a lot of other things that you
could go into but bitcoin there's always
a special place
i got inspired by crypto by blockchain
and
bitcoin in general i decided to create a
collection of crypto digital art
and physical art and nft art because i
was really inspired by blockchain what
do you think is the biggest
challenge that cryptocurrency is having
today we need to figure out a way to
make it more scalable faster
transactions and lower fees for people
so it's much more usable
and we can apply it to more industry
educating the masses
people really understanding what they're
getting into and learning how to protect
themselves
building trust with people it's going to
take some time for people you know the
common person to be like okay this makes
sense this is something i want to
bet in and and trust with my money
everyone wants to know if the u.s is
going to ban crypto or what just
happened in turkey or with india or
china
right so i i don't think that's really a
big worry here the
the regulators are really embracing this
inflation is a thief and you want to
prevent that as much as you can
because it's not easy it used to be you
had a wallet and it used to be
you know some file or some hard drive on
your computer now we have
you know while it's on our phone but
there's still a lot of scams
and fishing and other things that happen
that kind of make people wary of getting
into the space
i guess the con is just still waiting to
see it rise
i've been special with crypto because
i'm afraid of the regulations i always
say the government is the biggest jack
voice
you could say that you could lose money
when it comes to paper money as an
example
what percentage of your money is in cash
is in the stock market is in crypto
talk asset allocation so we're all in on
ethereum we don't even have bank
accounts anymore
we use bitpay we liquidate our assets
onto
you know usd through whenever we need to
use them and we're kind of pretty much
over banks
i'm 99 crypto i keep enough cash in the
bank to pay bills and the rest of my
money is working for me and
appreciating against the dollar oh
definitely one percent at least you know
we'll see where it keeps going but you
know didn't want to didn't want to bet
the
bet everything in it didn't want to bet
the house at it but yeah put a
put a put one percent in right now if
you're not looking into crypto where do
you think the best place to
invest would be amazon google
traditional stock market type things
small businesses honestly
because go on yeah because they can
continue on to become a lot bigger if
you invest in them and help them out
what's the number one thing you've
learned since getting involved do your
research
make a well-educated decision before you
jump into anything i would say the
biggest thing is emotional discipline
these markets are wild and once you
discipline yourself
to buy and hold for the long term like
you do with any market and you can do a
stocks and a lot of strategies you kind
of set your mind at ease
and then you tend to build wealth over
time final piece of advice
um buy bitcoin because if you snooze you
lose invest save that money
rick can we ask you one question about
crypto what's your best piece of advice
when it comes to crypto
roll the dice roll the dice ready i'm
just playing yeah if you know it you
know it man
thanks rick crypto is off the chain
right
now the blockchain it's becoming clear
and clear
that crypto is not going anywhere and is
likely here to stay
so the general consensus that you at
home need to get more educated
more informed and get invested and
before you can get invested
you need to save that money all we talk
is money